Deutschland ist eine Exportnation.
Aber die Landessprache gilt
nicht als gefragtes Gut.
Grund dafür könnte eine
gewisse Schwellenangst sein.
Das weltweite Image der deutschen
Sprache ist noch ausbaufähig.
Echt schwer.
Sehr streng, und ich denke
eine eher militärische Sprache.
Es klingt etwas hart, vielleicht
auch schroff – ziemlich schroff.
Trotzdem erlebt Deutsch seit
einigen Jahren einen Popularitätsschub:
Die Sprachkurse an den Goethe-
Instituten sind stark nachgefragt.
Deutsch zählt nach Englisch,
Französisch und Chinesisch
zu den beliebtesten
Fremdsprachen der Welt.
Der Linguist Ulrich Ammon untersucht
die globale Verbreitung des Deutschen.
In seinem Buch „Die Stellung der
deutschen Sprache in der Welt“
hat er Zahlen gesammelt
und liefert Gründe für den Zuwachs.
Es ist ein Beleg dafür, dass das
Ansehen Deutschlands in der Welt
in der letzten Zeit
gewachsen ist, und die Hauptbasis
dafür ist die wirtschaftliche Stabilität.
Um das rankt sich alles andere,
strahlt aus auf alles andere, dass man dann
plötzlich auch die deutsche Kultur
wieder interessanter findet als früher.
Wer die Landessprache spricht, hat bessere
Job-Aussichten bei deutschen Unternehmen.
Auch sportliche Erfolge wie
die der deutschen
Fußball-Nationalmannschaft
fördern das Interesse.
Und dann ist da ja noch Berlin. Die deutsche
Hauptstadt gilt nach wie vor als hip.
Ein Sprachkurs in Berlin ist
darum besonders populär.
Hier am GLS Sprachzentrum kommen
280 Schüler aus 23 Nationen zusammen.
Einige davon sind schon seit Jahren dabei –
und haben diverse Favoriten
in dem für seine zusammengesetzten Worte
berüchtigten Sprachschatz gefunden.
Vaterschaftsklage.
Nachtspeicherofen.
Haftpflichtversicherung.
Die Schüler kommen aus Südamerika, Asien
und vor allem aus den Ländern Südeuropas.
Damit ist die Klasse ein fast
repräsentatives Abbild der Regionen,
in denen Deutsch besonders gefragt ist.
Kopfzerbrechen bereitet allen
hier die Grammatik –
etwa der Brasilianerin
Adriana Monteiro Vieira.
Ich würde sagen, dass es eine schöne
Sprache ist, aber schwer zu lernen.
Ich sage immer, dass ... ich werde
nie Deutsch beherrschen,
aber ich werde [es] immer versuchen.
Einige deutsche Begriffe haben
es in anderen Sprachen
zu Modewörtern gebracht –
etwa Zeitgeist, Gemütlichkeit
oder die angesagte Vorsilbe „über-“.
Germanismen sind neuerdings
auch in der internationalen Restaurant-
und Bar-Szene en vogue.
„Fette Sau“ heißt ein
Restaurant in New York.
In Kopenhagen gibt es „Heidis Bier Bar“
und in London das „Katzenjammers“.
Der Journalist Sven Siedenberg
hat den ausgewanderten
deutschen Wörtern nachgespürt.
Sein Buch „Besserwisser beim
Kaffeeklatsching“
stellt die populärsten Beispiele vor.
Das Deutsche hat sicherlich
ein Stück weit Exotik zu bieten.
Man verschafft sich damit ein bisschen
das Gefühl, etwas Besonderes zu sein.
Man verschafft sich vielleicht auch das
Gefühl, zur Avantgarde zu gehören.
Das verspürt aber längst
nicht jeder Deutschlerner.
Die Vorurteile gegen die
Sprache halten sich beständig
– etwa in Venezuela, der
Heimat von Ernesto Isaaccura.
Ja, dass es eine ganz schwierige
Sprache ist und auch ganz hart,
also, es tönt nicht so
schön, also so: „örörör“.
Kein Wunder: Noch heute
wird in Hollywood
der Kasernenhofton der
Nazis als Stilmittel eingesetzt.
… mit ihrem betrunkenen, rüpelhaften
Benehmen strapaziert.
Sie schreien immer und sie sprechen
sehr stark und immer hart.
Der deutschen Rock-Band Rammstein
gelang mit der Überspitzung
dieses Teutonentums sogar
eine Weltkarriere.
Reise, Reise, Seemannreise.
Jeder tut's auf seine Weise.
Und Rammstein weckte damit vor allem
bei ausländischen Jugendlichen
das Interesse an der Sprache.
Am Anfang konnte ich kein R sprechen
und habe ich das geübt mit
– wie sagst du … wie sagt man – mit
Wasser oder nach [dem] Zähneputzen: „rrrrr“.
Ein Riesen-Hit bei YouTube
war dieses Video,
das den Klang des Deutschen mit
dem anderer Sprachen vergleicht.
Von wegen Deutsch ist bierernst: Die
Sprache hat durchaus ihre lustigen Seiten!